To construct a jellyfish topology, one can simply take
the following steps. First, pick a random switch pair
with free ports for which the switch pair are
not already neighbors. Next, join them with a link,
and repeat this process until no further links can
be added. If a switch remains with greater than
or equal to two free ports, which might happen
during the incremental expansion by adding a new switch,
these switches can be incorporated in the
topology by removing a uniform random existing
link and adding links to that switch.
For a particular equipment cost, using identical
equipment, the jelly fish topology can achieve
increased capacity by supporting twenty five percent
more servers. This higher capacity is achieved
because the paths through the topology are
shorter than they would be in a
Fat tree topology. Consider a topology with sixteen
servers, twenty switches, and a fixed degree of
four for both the fat tree topology and
the jellyfish random graph. In the fat
tree topology, only four of 16 servers are
reachable in less than five hops. In contrast,
in the jellyfish random graph, there are 12
servers reachable. By making more servers reachable along shorter
paths, jellyfish can increase capacity over a
conventional Fat tree topology. So while Jellyfish shows some promise, there are
certainly some open questions. First, how close
are these random graphs to optimal, in
terms of the optimal throughput that could
be achieved for a particular set of equipment.
Second, what about typologies where switches are
heterogeneous with different numbers of ports or
link speeds. From a system design perspective,
the random topology model could create problems with
physically cabling the datacenter network, and there
are also questions about how to perform routing
or congestion control without the structure of
a conventional datacenter network like a fat tree.